MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, my
name is Martin Omander,
and I welcome you to
Google Root Access,
the show featuring
actionable startup advice.
My guest today is
Nathan Beckord.
Welcome on the show, Nathan.
NATHAN BECKORD:
Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you're a
co-founder of Foundersuite.
And could you tell us
about your startup?
NATHAN BECKORD: Sure.
Foundersuite is a collection
of productivity tools
for entrepreneurs.
We have five web
apps and a collection
of about 80 templates,
spreadsheets,
documents for entrepreneurs.
And the way it came about
is for the past 10 years
or so I've been consulting
with start-ups, usually
in a finance or
biz dev capacity,
and I saw common repeating
mistake start-ups were making,
common needs start-ups needed.
You know, I worked with
about 150 companies
and just saw a lot of patterns
of success and failure
and built spreadsheets
and templates
to help them through common
operating and financial
activities.
And then from that,
turned that into what
we have today, which
is Foundersuite.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh great.
So you are a startup for
start-ups, a meta-startup,
if you will.
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: How's business?
NATHAN BECKORD:
Business is good.
Yeah, we launched
in June of 2013
and we're up to over 4,500
start-ups on the platform now.
We're adding about 20
to 25 start-ups a day,
so things are rockin'.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh great.
Congratulations.
So you say that
you've seen many,
many start-ups and you've seen
things that work and things
that don't.
What's one of the main
challenges that start-ups
could do better at do you think?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, you know
fund-raising is the perennial
challenge of strat-ups--
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, indeed.
NATHAN BECKORD: One that
a lot of entrepreneurs
do poorly or wrong.
And you can actually hurt
yourself if you do it wrong.
I see a lot of start-ups
that take the spray and pray
approach, right?
They put together a pitch or
sometimes a business plan,
and they just blast it
out to every VC email
address they can find.
Or they're pinging
people through LinkedIn
that have no relevance
to what they're doing.
The spray and pray
approach doesn't work.
Not only is a not going
to get you meetings.
It's completely ineffective,
but it could actually
come back and hurt you.
If you do eventually find a
warm introduction to an investor
and they see that they've
added you to their spam filter
before, you know it could
be a signal that you really
don't know what you're doing,
that you didn't take the time
to learn how the fund
raising process works,
and that you were just
spamming investors.
So instead, we really
champion a very laser focused,
targeted approach
to fund raising.
This means finding
the right investors
by geography,
location, and stage.
It also means finding the warm
connection into those investors
that you've identified.
As one example, in
our investor CRM tool,
we have a LinkedIn plug-in,
a plug in to engines API.
So if I'm trying to
reach Mark Andreessen,
he's on my targeted
list, I can see
who can connect me
to Mark Andreessen.
So that's one example of
how people do it wrong
and how they can do better.
MARTIN OMANDER: Do it better.
Great.
So you said-- you mentioned
sort of the Trinity of location,
stage, and industry.
Could you tell me a
bit more about that?
What's the right way
to think about those
if you're in startup?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, you know.
This is pretty
common sense stuff,
but it's still something
that a lot of entrepreneurs
in their hunger to
raise money do wrong.
First is industry.
Right, this should
be pretty intuitive,
but if you're a
fin tech start up
you should be
looking at investors
that have a stated preference
for financial technology.
If you're a mobile app or a
social, if your to B to B or B
to C, obviously if you're in
medical devices or something
else, you should
really be filtering out
any investors that
don't specifically
play in your space.
That's the industry.
The stage is something that I
see people do wrong sometimes.
They'll identify a
fin tech investor
but that fin tech investor
does B or C rounds, later
stage investing, whereas they're
really at the C or A round.
You know, they might take a
meeting just to kick the tires
and hear what you're
doing, but it's
very unlikely they're
going to investment in you,
because their fund has
a charter to invest
in a certain stage of business.
So getting the stage
right, whether it's
C series A or
later is important.
And then finally location.
Most investors are pretty
specific about this.
If you're in Boston
and New York,
you invest in start-ups
in your local area.
Silicon Valley holds true.
Some investors will play
outside their sandbox,
but a joke I heard yesterday
at a conference, actually
I can't claim
credit for this, is
that most investors
want to invest
within one Tesla
charge of their office.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's great.
NATHAN BECKORD: That's
getting the location right.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Yeah, it's funny.
I remember in the
late '90s the pundits
were talking about
the death of distance.
Distance wouldn't matter.
But you're saying
it matters a lot.
NATHAN BECKORD: Still
matters a lot, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Still matters.
So this is really helpful as
far as finding investment.
Does this, what you just
mentioned about industry
and stage and
location carry over
into other parts of
what a startup does?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah
it certainly does.
I think media relations
and PR is very analogous.
If you're looking to get people
to write about your startup,
you're looking to
get coverage, you're
looking to get attention
as most entrepreneurs are,
you know again,
doing it wrong is
finding a list
online somewhere--
and you see these
published sometimes--
of email addresses
of journalists,
and blasting a press release
out to all those lists.
You're going to piss them off.
Journalists hate it
when they get spammed.
And again, they know when
they're being spammed.
A better, more
appropriate way to do it
is to find journalists,
to find publications
that cover your space,
and then to narrow down
further to the journalist whose
beat it is to cover your space.
And then ideally, if
you can also figure out
what they're currently
writing about,
their editorial
calendar, that's golden.
We try to enable some of
that with our media CRM tool.
We pull in their
Twitter streams, right?
So if a journalist is putting
out to their followers
that they're looking for
an expert in security,
or internet of things, you
know that's a great time
to pitch if that's
what you're doing.
So kind of tracking
and following--
MARTIN OMANDER: So
they actually tell us
what they're looking for.
NATHAN BECKORD: They often do.
Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh that's great.
NATHAN BECKORD: And
so that's perfect.
That's the exact right
time to be pitching them.
And then finally one other
little bit of advice there.
To the extent you can pay
it forward to a journalist
and build a relationship in
advance of pitching them,
that's great too.
If you can give them a
scoop, some breaking news,
I mean that's what
they live and die for.
If you can get them
a tip or anything
you can do to help them
out in advance of pitching
will go a long way when it's
your time to pitch them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh I see.
Great.
So we are here in the
middle of Silicon Valley,
and a lot of your start-ups
are in Silicon Valley.
Many of our viewers,
perhaps most of our viewers,
are not here.
What should you do if you're
not in a place where there's
a lot of media
outlets or investors,
or if you find that there's
nobody covering your industry?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah.
If there's no uncovering
industry or there's no nearby,
obviously you could pivot.
You could change
what you're doing.
I don't necessarily
recommend that.
You could move, of course.
We see just a flood
of U-hauls coming
into Silicon Valley
in recent years,
and I'm sure you've
seen that too.
Or what I see a lot of start-ups
do, especially ones that maybe
are based abroad, in
Australia, or Europe,
or elsewhere, or Asia, they'll
have one or two people here
to really be the scout
in the Valley, right?
To be the one that's going up
and down Sand hill Road or 2nd
Street corridor in San
Francisco talking to investors.
You know, with journalists I
don't think location matters
quite as much, but
it's still always great
if you can ping a
journalist and invite him
to coffee or something.
I did that two weeks ago and
got a guy, a writer from Inc.
to come out and meet for
beers at Thirsty Bear.
It was great.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
Yeah.
NATHAN BECKORD:
And then finally,
if you can't find anyone who's
really covering your space,
or investors that declare
their interest in your space,
that's not necessarily
a bad thing.
If you're doing
something really so
unique that no one's
following it yet,
that could be a huge advantage.
Journalists and investors are
always looking for the outlier,
right?
They're looking to break news.
They're looking for that unique
different thing, not the nth
iteration of a social
photo sharing app, right?
So play to your stengths.
If you have something truly
unique, that can go a long way.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh great.
Well thank you so much
for coming in and sharing
your experiences with
us today, Nathan.
NATHAN BECKORD: Thank you
very much for having me.
Appreciate it.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bitly/applyrootacces.
That's it for now.
See you next time.